do you wish you made this film 10 years
earlier yeah but it would not be
possible but I wish honestly I wished
really that's interesting you why do you
know yes 10 years ago it would be much
more important to tell this story the
people because I I believe if I would
have told that film 10 years ago it
might have helped people to understand
better the situation on the ground in
Iraq and in the whole Middle East on the
other hand in this 10 years the social
media changed the whole Arab world so
intensively and also in my own
reflection on on the ground I think 10
years ago my film will be maybe even
more depressive because now I see
through the social media much more hope
of change in the Arab world which was 10
years ago not so obvious it was not so
obvious you know but but the Arab Spring
in 2011 showed how a new revolution will
will be created and at the same moment
we are talking now in Lebanon and Iraq
there are organizing the young people
young artists politicians and geo
members through the social media the
biggest demonstration ever in Iraq and
in Lebanon against the government's
against corruption and calling for a
secular government and this is really
something incredible and it's a pity
that I don't read that in the newspaper
here you know but on on facebook and on
twitter i get every time we need a
message out what's going on you know and
and it's very promising so i would say
10 years ago yeah it would be
politically wiser to do that film but
ten years later like today it represents
much more the the hope and the spirit of
the new generation in the Middle East
you